okay so we're gonna do one more example
here this is one with you can use
um footage right and so this one's
inspired by um an espn monday night
football package i referenced uh in a
previous set of lessons uh for this
distressed texture this is
something i saw them do
on the monday night football package and
i thought it was really cool
so i'm going to do something somewhat
similar
call this basketball we're going to
go into our raster here and we're going
to find
the basketball player
so this right here is a layer
that
i went into photoshop and i cut this guy
out okay
and his name is alec burks i believe
he's a nba player
and all i did was this was the original
image and i just went in and cut him out
with the quick selection tool
and ended up
with this cut out just like this
so
here we are back in after effects and
i'm just going to start by making this
layer 3d
and i am going to make sure we've got
their alpha channel there we go
it's turned on i'm going to go up to
layer new camera
and we're going to stick with 35
millimeter again just to make it very
easy
zoom out
so we can get the right framing for how
we want it to kind of look so something
like that
um and we're also going to bring in this
image i found on unsplash
and this is just going to be our
background layer so we'll do
a 3d on this layer as well
and we're just going to push this layer
way back in
z space
maybe something like
oh 1800 something like that
and with that layer pushed way back in z
space we can scale now at this point
larger than 100
and keep you know an okay resolution
so we're going to do something like
somewhere in here around 245 or so i'm
going to
drag up
this
so it kind of looks like maybe he's
standing on this
uh cord i know it's not you know totally
believable but just something i want
just like a background image that's
going to be out of focus
so it's not super important that we see
it
in full detail here
next i'm going to do is i'm going to
duplicate this layer
and
i'm going to start
positioning these back
in space
and i found that
around negative 900 works
and i'm gonna go ahead and switch to two
views so you can see what's going on
here and this view will switch to custom
and i'm just going to duplicate these
guys going back
and we'll go
now negative 1800 with 900 plus another
900
duplicate again
negative
2700
and we'll duplicate it one more time and
we'll do
[Music]
negative 3600
something like that and
our camera let's make sure our camera is
set to so it's set to two node i'm gonna
use one node for this
so it's one node
and
let's set a keyframe for that
okay
and let's go ahead and let's just reset
this to 960
540.
and we'll do
maybe third negative 3100 or so
um we're gonna two seconds forward
because this is where we want everything
to
uh we want the
basketball players to be in position at
this point so this is where their
keyframes are set
right click keyframe assistant easy ease
and we'll go back to the beginning and
we're going to make them all the same
positions zero
zero zero pixels and z space so you'll
see they're all going to go up right up
here when i hit zero boom so they're all
lined up right here so it looks like
there's just one layer here but
actually
they're all
right there lined up one on top of the
other
so the next thing we're gonna do is now
we need to reposition our camera so we
can see the top of his head
so something like
maybe like this
i'm also going to take the background
transparency down
maybe like 28 i just want to be kind of
dark back there it doesn't it's not the
focus of the piece so it just needs to
kind of just be back there
give us some reference to where we're at
so
as these guys kind of push back our
camera needs to push back as well so
we're gonna hit c to zoom out and we're
just kind of moving this guy back
and moving them over to the side like
this
i'll do a little bit of rotation as well
so i'm going to hit r for rotation
i'm going to set a keyframe
right click easy ease and move all these
to the front the reason i set keyframes
for all of these is because i don't know
exactly
what rotation property i'm going to work
with so i like to just set keyframes so
i if i do move a rotation property it
sets a new keyframe and i don't have to
worry about losing my original position
i'm going to right click again easy ease
on the position keyframes
so
let's see here
now if you hold down shift when you
rotate as well it's only going to
rotate on whatever axis so i'm rotating
i'm dragging left to right so it's just
going to keep it on that x-axis
i'm going to turn off two views here
maybe zoom out a little bit more
and at this point it's just about
getting my composition exactly how i
want it to be
something like that and then it'd be
kind of cool to see like um if this was
like a piece for like an opening um
about him that maybe it says his name so
i'll type in alec
berks
not a huge basketball fan
i love the nfl
and i'm using a font here called
typeface called agencyfb
and i'm just gonna make this 3d
so when i made it three you can see all
when i made it 3d you can see that it
kind of disappeared back in here it's
still there it's just behind this layer
right here
i'm just going to drag it on the x
something like that
i'm also going to turn on depth of field
and i'm going to go back to my two views
and i'm just going to crank up my
aperture here
and it'd be kind of cool to focus in on
maybe like this third guy right here
which is right yeah maybe one more
actually this guy right here so let's
set our focus distance there
and we're actually going to go to top
view here
so let's go back to that guy it was this
guy right
here so i want my focus distance to
cross
the boundary here of the the bounding
box of this layer
so i'm gonna increase the focus distance
here so focus right there and there he
is he's in focus i'm going to crank up
the aperture so that the foreground and
the background
are both blurred and then i want to make
sure that my type since i'm focused here
my type needs to be lined up there and
you can see the types way back there so
we'll bring
the type that's crossing the focal plane
right there
hit s for scale i'm going to shrink it
down just a little bit there
maybe bring it up
something like so
go back to one view
and see what it looks like let's render
this out
it looks pretty dope i'm just going to
change the position on this background
just a little bit
and you can see a weird artifact
happening here where this layer is
crossing with with this first player
layer there's like some transparency
going on there
and it shouldn't be because there's the
players 100 transparency
and this
background is
pushed back
uh so sometimes when you work with 3d
layers there can be some really weird
things that happen where the layers
cross each other and do some weird
things so a really quick fix to do this
is just to create a new adjustment layer
so layer new adjustment layer
and just by adding that adjustment layer
between the two 3d layers it solves the
problem so you can see there now there's
no longer any transparency issues
i call these
a cutter
and you just need to lock that layer so
it's just there to create to get rid of
any weird things that happen
um
so you can see here how it looks
uh it looks really cool uh with a very
simple effect of just separating
elements into 3d space
flat artwork in 3d space you could use
this for photos for graphics for footage
that's rotoscoped
and then just really quickly i just want
to show you if we were to
duplicate the camera turn off our bottom
camera
and
just to close all these up
so there's no confusion here if i was to
make this camera
a
two node camera
you can see there immediately that the
position changed
so
i'm actually going to go ahead and just
reset this camera
turn off all of our keyframes
and
reset
and
i'm gonna go ahead and just move
the camera
into place so with moving with this
camera tool here uh with the pan or the
zoom it's going to move
the
the track x and y is going to go ahead
and move the entire camera you can see
down point of interest and position
moves
so it's going to
move both those where the zoom out the
tracks z
is only going to move the position of
the camera it doesn't move the anchor
point the point of interest
but here we are we're set up i'm going
to set a position only keyframe set it
to
keyframe easy ease go two seconds in
and
i'm gonna pull the camera
back in z
so we can see what's going on here
and i'm moving on the x
because remember that point of interest
is
sitting right here the entire time
it's right there sorry i had the wrong
point so this might be an animation
where point of interest the two note
camera actually helps make maybe make a
little bit smoother motion because i
noticed on the one node camera there's a
little bit of a of a kind of a rock to
the motion
so i want to get this solved here
so
maybe something like that
i could just cheat this
over just a hair just like that
make sure okay we're seeing it there
and maybe see a little bit more of the
players here maybe so i can see the back
the name on the back so maybe something
like
this
well i can't see the back but
if we're going to see part of the back
right there
and then again taking the
background
so now let's check out what this looks
like
and there we go so that's a much
smoother motion
with this effect and i actually like
this one a little bit better i would
probably come in and fine-tune
placement of the text
things like that
um it's a little bit out of the focus
plane now
um if i go back to two views horizontal
and i turn on
so there's our focal plane there's our
text
bring it forward
something like so
and there you go so hopefully uh you get
the idea here of what you can do with uh
3d layers 2d layers in 3d space
inside of after effects i call it two
and a half d
a very powerful technique
and can really open up possibilities
when it comes to motion graphics
with after effects
[Music]
you